[Musik]
xinyu meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer neuen
episode minecraft mit luca staffel 2 in
der letzten folge waren wir hier stehen
geblieben wo wir hier den ganzen bereich
mal bisschen klein gemacht haben ihr
sterbt ihr der ein oder andere baum und
der weg war hier so komisch durchlöchert
deswegen hab ich das jetzt alles
zugebaut ist braucht halt hier noch ein
bisschen bis zu ein paar stellen hier
wieder komplett von dem gras befallen
wurden allerdings sieht auf jeden fall
schon sehr schön und clean aus da wurde
mir auch dass hier und in die kommentare
geschrieben und die idee finde ich ganz
cool weil es mich so ein bisschen der
minecraft mit der staffel 1 erinnerte
und wie er da so einen kleinen bezug
schaffen können wenn wir hier so einen
kleinen teilchen machen dann kann man da
entspannter laufenbrücke oder irgendwie
so können wir mal gucken wie wir das
alles muss endlich umgesetzt werden und
die sache ist allerdings was mir auch
geschrieben wurde darum soll es heute
auch als erstes gehen ist das hier ich
habe in der letzten folge gefragt hey
leute wie seht ihr das hier mit dem
brunnen soll bestehen bleiben oder nicht
ich war eigentlich gerne
ich war eigentlich eher der ansicht dass
der brunnen abgebaut werden sollte weil
wir dadurch halt ein bisschen mehr platz
haben wir können hier den vernünftigen
marktplatz vielleicht errichten und
haben schlussendlich hier ja so eine
kleine bessere möglichkeit von a nach b
zu kommen wenn ich mal diese blöden
brunn drum herum laufen muss die sache
ist allerdings dass sehr viele von euch
denn nicht nur der kommentar den ich
gerade eingeblendet habe sondern auch
andere leute mit wirklich hunderten
tausenden likes unter den kommentaren
jahren geschrieben der brunnen muss da
bleiben das ist der mittelpunkt vom dorf
den kannst du nicht einfach so abhauen
luca ich weiß dass ich ihnen gerade
trotzdem abbau allerdings was habt ihr
bei dem kommentar gewinne nicht
eingeblendet habe will ich ihn halt auf
eine andere höhe einfach setzen deswegen
brauche ich jetzt hier einfach mal das
komplette wasser zu damit wäre einfach
hier ganz easy die steinmauern abbauen
können dann werde ich den bohnen eins zu
eins wie er hier stand damit nicht
irgendwann mir sagen kann fasst es voll
verändert ich werde den eins zu eins
gleich wieder hier so hinbauen und euch
davon jetzt auch erstmal eine ganz kurze
time labs einblenden
[Musik]
so freuen ich unterbreche die teils
jetzt einmal ganz kurz weil ich
eigentlich gesagt habe kommen kurze
plötzlich macht den brunnen hier eine
ebene tiefer damit dass ihr alles passt
die sache ist allerdings und es hat der
hat gesehen dass ich mich primär um das
haus gekümmert habe was ich abgebaut
habe weil hier vorne das haus auf seiner
hohen ebene stand dass ich das
eigentlich hier so runterziehen wollte
die ganze erde wie ich das hier hinten
gemacht habe hier das finde ich sehr
geil dort war das hier so hoch geht man
kann wenn man will ich mal hochgehen man
könnte hier vorne auch so einen kleinen
trampelpfad hoch machen irgendwann
demnächst die sache ist allerdings dass
er sie nicht möglich war das haus so
hoch stand deswegen hab ich jetzt das
ganze haus extra abgebaut ich weiß ich
sehe auch schon die ganzen kommentare
von wegen bolt
mensch luca wollte einfach nur den
brunnen eine ebene tiefer packen jetzt
fängt der hier wieder andere mit alles
besser aus extra häuser abzubauen und so
hast du noch leid dass wir dadurch ein
bisschen zeit verlieren aber ich finds
dadurch wirklich schön und vielleicht
hat mir dann auch platz irgendwann im
nächsten umfeld zu bauen und
interagieren wir so richtig mit dem dorf
das hatten wir uns noch nie wir haben
immer nur die dörfer zumindest immer
dann mannschaft mit nur einer staffel
eins wenn ich jetzt haben die dörfer
immer nur genutzt um ja wirklich zu
handeln immer nur sonst weggesehen und
das nicht wirklich schön gemacht
deswegen sich das heute auf jeden fall
machen die sonne geht unter deswegen
gehe ich noch mal ganz gut schlafen und
euch jetzt mal wirklich den brunnenbauer
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde hier vorne jetzt
die glocke in die mitte und jetzt noch
hier an adel seiten eine fackel dran so
dass der brunnen auch beleuchtet ist wir
können auch mal ganz kurz gucken ob die
glocke auch funktioniert indem wir uns
hinter grund einfach mal die villa
anschauen die rennen nämlich jetzt bei
leuten direkt rein in ihre häuser das
klappt auf jeden fall perfekt er da
hinten so doch noch seinen heute
vielleicht wacht das ist ein neues thema
dass ich abgebaut habe allerdings habe
ich das jetzt alles mit sehr schöner
gemacht ich hab den grundsätzlich direkt
in die mitte gesetzt weil dann kann man
hier ein bisschen herlaufen klar hier
fehlt jetzt noch irgendwie so eine
steinmauer mit einer laterne habe ich
jetzt gar nicht dabei allerdings ist
hier der berg deutlich schöner deutlich
abgerundet hat das habe ich jetzt auch
noch nicht so richtig gemacht aber
generell alles hier so ein bisschen
angepasst die treppe ihr passt perfekt
mit dem zwei abstand dem wir auch hier
oben haben und auf der anderen seite hin
und man kann jetzt hier ganz entspannt
durchlaufen ich bin mir meiner aufnahme
bei 45 minuten und ich wollte eigentlich
auch noch ein paar andere sachen
eingehen zum beispiel wurden
aufgeschrieben luca das mit dem tri top
das funktioniert nur deswegen nicht weil
die blätter irgendwie noch holz berührt
haben oder so da auf jeden fall story
filmen und wissen ich will jetzt erst
mal ein paar sachen hier noch drin lager
neben die ich vorerst nicht mehr
benötige die sache ist allerdings dass
die kiste jetzt auch schon voll ist ich
lass dir jetzt einfach mal stehen bzw
macht es ja auch ein bisschen schöner
dass die kiste nicht so dumm in der luft
herum schwebt so und dann haben jetzt
auf jeden fall das erste von den zwei
zielen für heute erledigt das war
nämlich der brunnen und jetzt kommen wir
auch schon direkt zum 2 ziel und zwar
wird das nicht sein dass ich jetzt den
teich hinbauen das war glaube ich ein
bisschen zu viel bauen in einer folge
sondern ich werde mir einen zauber tisch
kräften das geht ein bisschen schneller
als das bisherige mit dem brunnen ich
wusste jetzt natürlich auch nicht dass
ich mich da so die ganze zeit
reinsteigern werde mit dem ganzen bauen
ich denke jedoch dass das mit dem zauber
tisch jetzt deutlich schneller gehen
sollte denn wir haben bereits die zwei
diamanten wir haben auch dachte ich vier
obsidian oder noch mehr wir benötigen
nämlich nur einfach bücher die kann ich
generell mal mitnehmen weil wir uns
damit noch bücherregale machen müssen
und benötigen zwei diamanten und vier
obsidian im größten notfall muss ich
jetzt natürlich noch mal irgendwo unter
einer höhle gehen und obsidian abbauen
aber ich dachte das sich irgendwo noch
was hatte oder bin ich gerade dumm ich
schaue noch mal hier vorne in meiner
kiste und hier haben wir allerdings auch
nichts ich weiß nicht ob ich die
irgendwie verbaut habe oder irgendwie so
jedoch kann ich mir theoretisch mal ganz
kurz einfach meine diamant spitzhacken
nehmen um bei unserem portal
provisorisch die unteren beiden abbauen
die beiden unteren ersetzt sich jetzt
einfach mal durch basalt damit zumindest
sonne leichte ähnliche struktur weise
sind jetzt nicht ganz so ähnlich aus
aber zumindest ein bisschen und jetzt
können uns auch direkt einen zauber
tisch kraft nicht kräfte mit denen
nämlich weil wir so lange wir sind
vorangekommen müsse nun im projekt hier
da ist jetzt optisch bekomme ich dafür
einen schiefen wenn ich irgendwie kann
ich also ganz entspannt erstmal hier
wieder stetig abbauen ich brauche auf
jeden fall erstmal ein paar bücherregal
ich glaube ich hatte hier keine mehr
drin perfekt allerdings mache ich mir
jetzt einfach mal 14 bücherregale ich
hoffe mal dass sie ausreichend sonst
kann ich auch einfach jetzt mal ganz
kurz dass sie noch so viel machen wie
geht also 17 stück habe ich jetzt sogar
das tannenholz brett deans gewöhnt kommt
da wieder rein die bücher alle wieder
hier rein und jetzt hat die frage wo ich
das hin setzte die sache ist halt dass
ich eigentlich in meiner hobbys höhle
unten so einen kleinen zauber raum rein
machen wollte ich fand es allerdings
auch ganz coole minecraft genug a
staffel 1 wo wir wirklich so eine kleine
zauberinsel hatten ich könnte
theoretischen holzinger hinten machen
allerdings würde ich jetzt erst mal
provisorisch irgendwie machen dass man
hier einen kleinen weg runter gehen kann
die sache ist ja dass wir hier vorne
unsere kleine ablage haben wo noch der
braustätten drauf kommt das heißt es
macht eigentlich am meisten sinn wenn
ich hier irgendwie einen kleinen weg
unterbau nicht erzielen meinem
schlafzimmer ich mal ganz gut sie die
tür zu und auch nicht in unserer küche
deswegen würde ich einfach mal diesen
crafting table hier abbauen weil ich ja
hier vorne in der ecke auch noch einen
habe der sollte eigentlich ausreichen
und zur not kann ich einfach drüber
laufen und hier dann so einen kleinen
weg runter wo ich dann auch mal ganz
kurz mir leitern rolle okay jetzt
bereits unten im inventar freuen ich
habe tatsächlich gerade noch die vier
obsidian gefunden die ich dachte dabei
gehabt zu haben scheint sein
100 auf jeden fall waren etat ganzen in
dieser kiste die ich da eher
provisorisch eingestellt habe die
bringen jetzt auch nichts mehr ich kann
ihn gleich nochmal in das portal
einsetzen allerdings heißt es jetzt
erstmal so die sache ist jetzt
allerdings sind das dahinter
da oben auf der minimap oben rechts ich
habe mir auf jeden fall die leitern
geholt und ich möchte es natürlich alles
ein bisschen schön haben deswegen mache
ich das hier oben auch erst mal aus
fichtenholz damit es wenn wir von oben
runter gucken halt schön aussieht die
sache ist dann allerdings dass ich hier
rüber gehen werde so langsam von fichten
holzbrettern beispielsweise hier und
hier werde ich noch eins machen und dann
beispielsweise hier auch noch eins dann
werde ich allerdings erst mal ganz
kurzem eine fackel in die hand nehmen
dass man hier ein bisschen mehr erkennt
hier so rüber gehen in bruchstein
beispielsweise dann noch hier unten so
ein bisschen kies reinsetzen die teile
dann beispielsweise wieder durch
bruchstein ersetzen hier dann auch mal
zum normalen steigen lassen das ist
einfach wenn man von oben runter geht
man sieht okay man bewegt sich immer
mehr in richtung einer höhle die geht
man dann noch ein bisschen weiter runter
ich weiß nicht wie weit runter wir
wirklich schlussendlich gehen müssen
diese beiden steine entfernt ich zum
beispiel noch mal packe ich hier einen
keaton und bruchsteinen dann können wir
hier auch mal einen ersten stein
ziegeleien packen hier vorher dann
wieder einen kies rein hierfür hab ich
dann beispielsweise auch mal so glatte
steinstufen mitgenommen die man nochmal
hinsetzen könnte
oh mein gott oh mein gott erschien auch
zwei ändern wenn einfach vor bin ich
denn jetzt schon wieder gelandet das ist
die das ist die höhle die sich unter
meiner hobbit hülle befindet also unter
männer unter mein gott ich bin da auch
noch älter ich will ich will ich
will dir meinen traum reinbauen
was denken die verdi wind ich werde das
jetzt einfach mal zwei blöcke höher
machen ich werde euch noch ein bisschen
weiter runter damit man diese
enchantment geräuschen ich trinke ich
hier schon wieder drin
alter aber gut da mach ich das halt in
diese richtung hier vornherein genf habe
ich mir zeit gedacht dass man hier alles
so ein bisschen grob macht also mit zum
bruchsteinen gibt vorne habe ich euch
schon mal gezeigt in welche richtung es
gehen soll ich jetzt leider nicht so
viele verschiedene blöcke hiermit ich
habe mir zum beispiel noch
bruchsteinmauern die kommt man hier
gegen diese herunter hängen lassen dann
könnte man daran halt irgendwie zum
beispiel eine laterne hängen wenn ich
die erzieher und inventar kriegt diese
beispielsweise und dann habe ich hier
oben auch eine hang und dann kann man
den zauber scheint einfach hierhin
platzieren ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das
der allerbeste spot ist ob ich das jetzt
richtig angeordnet habe hier mit den
bücherregalen und so weiter und so fort
die sache ist allerdings dass wir erst
mal nicht so viele level und so sollte
es glaube ich erst mal funktionieren
oder ich habe jetzt hier noch ein paar
andere sachen die ich hier mitgenommen
habe die man hier irgendwie sollen die
decke klappen könnte dass das alles hier
so ein bisschen schöner aussieht so dann
nehme ich noch hier irgendwie so ein
teil dass das hier noch so runter und
werden jetzt hier zwei laternen das
sollte nicht aus auch ausreichen
vielleicht kann ich hier noch eine
irgendwie ins regal setzen oder so dann
ist hier noch eine irgendwie drin hier
machen wir noch so ein teil dran und
dann hier irgendwie noch so einen dingen
drauf oder so keine ahnung auf jeden
fall soll alles noch ein bisschen
vermoost aussehen das kommt natürlich
auch noch dafür brauchen wir ranken ich
habe auch überlegt das ganze noch mit
dingen zu machen mit beispielsweise
auch stellt retten können
wieso
hier noch eine so ich hatte auch
überlegt das ganze wird spinnenweben zu
machen da es allerdings die sache dass
ich die leider nicht
abgebaut habe dafür braucht man sich
eine schere und ich hab da nur die fäden
bekommen allerdings soll das ganze jetzt
quasi so sein und das seht ihr glaube
ich schon dass man hier einfach so lange
kommt und man kann weiß man okay hier
vorne ist halt braucht stand zum brauen
und hier vorne kann man runter gehen und
dann kommt man so in so eine art höhle
und kanada unten verzaubern ich habe
jetzt zwar gerade nichts im inventar wir
können allerdings trotzdem mal testen
irgendwie mit leisen axt und haben
keinen dings
rapstars
habe ich glaube ich generell noch nie
abgebaut
also ich hab meinen zauber raum wir
können jetzt auch zaubern
mir fehlt es allerdings an lapislazuli
aber gut meine lieben freunde da ich
hier jetzt bei eineinhalb stunden
aufnahmezeit bin und das video heute
noch online gehen sollen nicht gerade
etwas näher zu kommen und so weiter und
so fort würdigt das video ist allerdings
an der stelle auch beenden wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann das gerne einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da abonniert
main kanal und klickt auf die glocke
wenn ihr weitere videos minecraft mit
luca oder generell andere videos nicht
verpassen wollt übermorgen geht es mit
minecraft mit luca weiter morgen kommt
eine neue nicht lachen challenge auf
meinem kanal da könnt ihr auch gerne mal
vorbeischauen und ihr könnt auch gerne
auf meinem instagram vorbeischauen habe
ich mich neues foto hochgeladen
wenn ihr jetzt noch dran sein
kommentiert unter meinem neuen foto
zauber
ich glaube niemand ist generell jetzt
noch dran aber gut wir sehen uns
[Musik]